es vista como una sentencia decisiva
desde hong kong y probablemente dejará
un precedente en el sistema judicial en
el futuro dong jin kim se convirtió en
la primera persona en ser sentenciada
bajo la nueva ley de seguridad impuesta
desde beijing el día que entró en vigor
en 2020 también que golpeó un grupo de
policías con su motocicleta portando una
bandera que llamaba a la liberación de
hong kong este viernes fue declarado
culpable de terrorismo y de incitar a la
secesión las sentencias por los dos
cargos se cumplirán de manera
consecutiva que sumadas dan una
sentencia de nueve años grupos de
derechos humanos han criticado el juicio
por ir en contra de las normas
tradicionales de la ley se dio sin un
jurado y los tres jueces que lo
precedieron fueron todos escogidos por
la jefa del ejecutivo de hong kong
carril am
la ley de seguridad impuesta en hong
kong por las autoridades de beijing
fundamentalmente socava muchos de los
derechos aún garantizados para los
ciudadanos de hong kong
esto debilita la habilidad para que la
gente emoción juicio justo
y hasta ahora hay 60 personas en hong
kong acusadas por violaciones de esta
ley nacional de seguridad la legislación
fue impuesta en respuesta a las
protestas masivas que convulsionaron la
ciudad en 2019 y son vistas como una
manera de acabar con los opositores